>> THAT COULD BE A FINALS
PREVIEW.
>> ABSOLUTELY, CHUCK.
>> GREAT TO SEE KLAY COMING BACK
TOO.
>> IT'S THAT TIME.
>> IT'S TIME FOR --
>> OF COURSE BY THIS TIME ON
MONDAY NIGHT WE WILL HAVE A NEW
NATIONAL CHAMPION IN COLLEGE
FOOTBALL.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> I HOPE IT IS A NEW NATIONAL
CHAMPION IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL,
AND I HOPE THEY ARE WEARING
THIS.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
GEORGIA AND ALABAMA GOING AT IT
ON MONDAY IN INDIANAPOLIS FOR
ALL OF THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL --
>> IS THAT A REAL HELMET?
>> THAT IS REAL.
>> WHO YOU GOT, CHUCK?
>> HOLD ON!
DO NOT GET AHEAD OF YOURSELVES
BECAUSE I SPEAK FOR ALL GEORGIA,
GIVEN THREE.
ALABAMA WON THE S.E.C.
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME OVER GEORGIA.
I WAS THERE TO WATCH IT.
IT WAS PAINFUL.
GEORGIA FAVORED BY THREE OVER
ALABAMA IN THE TITLE GAME AND
SPEAK FOR ALL UNIVERSITY OF
GEORGIA FANS WHEN I SAY LET'S
JUST HOPE AND PRAY THAT CHARLES
BARKLEY DOES NOT PICK THE
UNIVERSITY OF GEORGIA TO WIN THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
BEFORE HIS PICK, A COUPLE OF
OTHER GEORGIA PRODUCTS AND THEIR
THOUGHTS.
>> IT IS MARIA.
I HAD ONE REQUEST, PLEASE,
PLEASE, DO NOT BET ON GEORGIA TO
WIN THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
WE DON'T NEED THAT BAD LUCK.
ALSO WHAT BOWL GAME IS AUBURN
PLAYING IN.
>> DO NOT BET WITH US IN THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
THIS ONE HAS TO COME BACK TO
ATHENS WITH US.
>> MARIA TAYLOR, YOU ARE ONE OF
MY FAVORITE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
YOU AND KATHRYN TAPPEN.
SHOUTOUT TO BOTH OF YOU LADIES.
IT'S THAT TIME.
THE GEORGIA BULLDOGS ARE GOING
TO WIN THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP.
GUARANTEE.
>> ABORT.
ABORT.
>> THE DOG IS HERE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF GEORGIA.
>> YOUR PAL.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT WAS AGGRESSIVE.
>> MAN.
>> THAT WAS VERY AGGRESSIVE.
>> HEY.
>> CHUCKSTER.
WHAT CAN I TELL YOU.
>> IT IS NOT TOO LATE.
>> NOPE.
>> NOT TOO LATE TO CHANGE YOUR
PICK.
>> GUARANTEE.
IT IS THE BULLDOG NATION, RISING
UP.
>> YOU ARE JUST DOING THAT
BECAUSE I AM HERE.
>> IT IS THEIR TIME, ERNIE.
IT IS THEIR TIME.
>> I HOPE IT IS THEIR TIME.
>> YOU COULDN'T SAY IT.
YOU COULDN'T SAY IT.
>> IT IS THEIR TIME.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE HARRY.
>> HARRY, I'M SORRY, MAN.
THERE IS NOTHING I CAN DO.
THERE IS NO CONTROL.
>> CAN I SEE THAT IN SLOW
MOTION?
>> GOLLY.
>> GO DAWGS.
>> OH.